like for you
would you say that
his death you know because I think it
was very like
I said dude just for America it was
right before the pandemic too
um how did I mean just for you man like
how did it hit you where were you at
when you found out about the news
I was in Atlanta
foreign
I didn't think it was that bad
the funny to my man and I was with
he started throwing up
wow
he don't even know Kobe this one this is
what I'm thinking about myself I'm like
damn he throwing up him with no Bean
it's cool yeah it's like one of those
things that I think probably because the
way it happened it don't even really
seem like real it's the way to me it's
the way it happened because it was now
like
we know that he's not here right
obviously you know what I'm saying right
but it just don't really seem real
you know it's it's pretty wild it's
definitely uh
like I said man as a basketball fan and
I I I'm a Laker hater I grew up rooting
against Kobe
and that [ __ ] I was like I've watched
this dude my whole [ __ ] childhood
like
I played this [ __ ] like like I
didn't know him but I felt like I knew
him you know what I'm saying
yeah it was it was a big loss man